Guten Abend, mein Name ist Udo Altundasch und ich bin der Riesabendas hier und würde jetzt gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich brauche erstmal ein paar persönliche Daten, dann sprechen wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerde. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Peter Kaiser.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vornamen langsam buchstabieren?
Ja, Peter P E T E R.
Nachnamen bitte.
Nachnamen?
Kaiser, K A I S E R. Wie Kaiser König.
Herr Kaiser, wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin 72.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 12. Juni 54.
54? Wie groß sind Sie?
1 Meter 78.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, immer so rund um die 80 Kilo.
Wer für Beschwerden haben Sie, Herr Kaiser?
Heftige Husten, der geht überhaupt nicht weg. Den habe ich jetzt schon 3 Wochen.
Jetzt habe ich aber irgendwie festgestellt, es ging mir immer schlechter und immer schlechter.
Jetzt habe ich gemerkt, dass ich hohes Fieber hatte und mir ist auch richtig schlecht.
Ich war vor 14 Tagen bei meinem Arzt, weil ich den Husten schon schlecht fand.
Der hat mir dann Hustenlöser verschrieben und ich habe das auch genommen.
ACC hieß das.
Aber das ist überhaupt nicht besser geworden.
Jetzt habe ich immer noch solche Husten. Jetzt muss ich vielleicht dazu sagen,
ich hatte einen Bruder, der hatte Lungkrebs.
Das habe ich natürlich selber ein bisschen Angst.
Der Husten macht mir wirklich zu schaffen und ich kann nachts nicht mehr gut schlafen, weil ich immer Husten muss.
Haben Sie auch Fieber?
Ja, das habe ich gerade gesagt. Das habe ich erst gar nicht gemerkt.
Dann habe ich gedacht, das ist ja warm draußen, deswegen schwitze du so.
Dann habe ich mal gewessen und da hatte ich dann das Gefühl, ich habe das Fieber.
Das war über 39 sogar.
Das war auch der Anlass, dass ich gesagt habe, jetzt muss ich aber mal hier in die Klinik gehen.
Leiden Sie auch unter Atemnot?
Nein, wenn die Hustenanfälle so ganz schlimm sind, habe ich manchmal das Gefühl, dass ich nicht so gut Luft kriege.
Aber überall quält mich das. Da kommt gar nichts raus. Es ist ganz trockener Husten.
Das ist sehr quälend.
Gibt es Wichtentauslöser für diese Beschwerden?
Das weiß ich. Ich kann das nicht an irgendwas festmachen.
Ja, das habe ich natürlich am Anfang gedacht. Ich habe mich erkältet oder so. Dann habe ich ein bisschen rumgehustet.
Aber das wird überhaupt nicht besser.
Haben Sie Gliederschmerzen?
Gliederschmerzen? Nein, das eigentlich nicht.
Oder andere Schmerzen?
Schmerzen? Ja, so ein bisschen habe ich Schmerzen beim Husten, wenn das so sehr angestrengt ist.
Aber Schmerzen sind nicht das Problem. Das Hauptproblem ist das lange Husten, das es jetzt schon so lange dauert, was mich total erschöpft.
Und jetzt habe ich halt gemerkt, dass ich so hohes Fieber habe.
Das Essen schmeckt mir natürlich auch nicht so wirklich gut, muss ich sagen.
Ich habe die letzten Tage nicht gut gegessen und geschlafen habe ich halt auch nicht gut.
Trifft dieser Husten tagsüber, nur tagsüber?
Nein, das ist Tag und Nacht. Nachts kann ich auch nicht gut schlafen.
Ich schlafe zwar schon mit erhöhtem Kopf, damit ich ein bisschen besser abhusten kann.
Aber zwischendurch wache ich dann auf und habe das Gefühl, ich muss dringend husten und trinke einen Schluck Wasser.
Und dann habe ich das Gefühl, es geht wieder ein bisschen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schlucken?
Beim Schlucken? Nein, da habe ich keine Probleme.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie schwitzen mehr.
Ja, ich habe gedacht, das liegt an der Wärme draußen, aber es scheint irgendwie doch am Fieber zu liegen.
Haben Sie auch Schüttelfrost?
Schüttelfrost? Nein, das hatte ich jetzt nicht.
Hätten Sie unter Brust enge Gefühl?
Enge Gefühl in der Brust? Wenn der Husten ganz schlimm ist, dann habe ich das schon, aber normal eigentlich nicht.
Haben Sie Herzrasen oder Herzstoffe anbemerkt?
Nein, mit dem Herz glaube ich, hat das nichts zu tun.
Haben Sie Sodbrennen oder müssen Sie Aufstoß?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Ist dieser Husten belastungsabhängig?
Ich kann mich gar nicht belasten. Ich hänge hier nur ein bisschen zu Hause herum.
Ich habe jetzt auch viel im Bett gesessen, weil ich mich schlapp gefühlt habe und krank.
Fühlen Sie sich müde und schwach?
Fühlen Sie sich schwach und müde?
Schwach und müde, ja, das trifft das schon.
Weil ich auch nachts nicht gut schlafe, das macht mich ganz fertig.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Ja, schon ein bisschen.
Müssen Sie erbrechen?
Nein, zum Glück nicht. So schlimm ist der Husten nicht.
Ich habe eigentlich eine Aversion gegen das Essen und das schmeckt nicht.
Ich fühle mich insgesamt ein bisschen übel.
Ist Ihnen schwitlig?
Schwitlig nicht, nein, zum Glück nicht.
Herr Kaiser, haben Sie in letzter Zeit Abworter zugenommen?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Eigentlich würde ich sagen, ist mein Gewicht stabil.
Ich habe mich aber jetzt auch nicht ständig gewogen, muss ich sagen.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Schlafstörungen.
Eine Schlafstörung oder eine Durchschlafstörung?
Nein, ich kann nicht durchschlafen, weil ich jetzt diesen Husten habe.
Aber ich schlafe auch sonst nie so gut, weil ich mit der Prostata Probleme habe.
Und da muss ich auch oft nachts auf die Toilette und da schlafe ich sowieso ein bisschen unruhig.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Nein, normalerweise eigentlich nicht, nein.
Haben Sie in Ihrer Stuhlveränderung bemerkt in letzter Zeit?
Farbe?
Nein, das ist immer ziemlich alles gleich.
Okay. Und haben Sie irgendwo Schwellungen bemerkt oder Knoten?
Schwellungen habe ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Außer bei der Prostata Probleme leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ja, in meinem Alter, kein Wunder.
Ich habe seit Jahren einen hohen Blutdruck.
Dann nehme ich regelmäßig eine Beta-Blocker und dann habe ich so einen Alterszucker.
Dann nehme ich Metformin ein. Das hat man vor 15 Jahren schon festgestellt.
Aber damit komme ich eigentlich ganz gut klar.
Und dann nehme ich nur morgens eine Tablette. Das ist auch wohl nicht so wild.
Ich muss nicht strenge Diät leben oder so.
Dann nehme ich eben noch Medikamente für diese Prostata-Geschichte.
Was nehmen Sie ein?
Das heißt Prostagut.
Wissen Sie die Dose?
Nein, kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen. Die Packung liegt da bei mir zu Hause auf dem Tisch.
Aber was da drauf steht, weiß ich nicht.
Kein Problem. Wir können später bei Ihrem Hausarzt fragen.
Und Metformin, wissen Sie diese Medikamentendose?
Metformin, das ist nicht die 1800er oder 850er oder so gibt es glaube ich.
Und einmal morgens?
Das nehme ich einmal morgens.
Also der Hausarzt kontrolliert das hin und wieder.
Aber das ist eigentlich so, dass es mir damit ganz gut geht.
Und gegen Bluthochdruck?
Ja, da nehme ich so einen Better Blocker ein. Ich weiß aber nicht wie der heißt.
Dann nehme ich aber auch nur morgens eine Tablette.
Einmal morgens?
Ja, ein morgens.
Gibt es noch andere Krankheiten?
Nee, das reicht ja auch völlig hin oder?
Ja. Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, also vor, schon lange her, schon als, ja so mit 50 sowas, da habe ich mal die Gallenblase rausgenommen bekommen.
Da waren wohl Steine und das hat die Wege verstopft oder hatte ich solche Schmerzen und ging es mir nicht gut und da ist die Gallenblase entfernt worden.
Vor 50 Jahren?
Nein, mit 50 Jahren.
Mit 50 Jahren, ok.
Haben Sie Allergie gegen irgendwas?
Das muss ich richtig überlegen. Eigentlich wüsste ich nicht, dass ich irgendwas nicht vertrage. Also eigentlich bin ich da ganz unempfindlich würde ich sagen.
Ich habe einige Fragen zu Ihren Lebensgewohnheiten, Herr Kaiser, rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich weiß auch, dass das für den Husten nicht so gut ist zurzeit, schmeckt mir das auch nicht. Muss ich ehrlich sagen, da rauche ich auch nicht so viel, aber ich rauche schon viele, viele Jahre ja und auch wirklich ein Päckchen am Tag.
Ein Päckchen.
Wie gesagt, die letzten Wochen habe ich das jetzt ein bisschen reduziert, aber ganz aufhören kann ich nicht gut.
Wenn Sie Unterstützung möchten, gibt es eine gute Programme zur Entwöhnung?
Ja, dafür bin ich glaube ich jetzt zu alt, das muss ich jetzt noch voll durchziehen bis zum Schluss.
Ok, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol, ja, also ich trinke so ein, zwei Schlagen Bier am Abend, ja.
Jeden Abend?
Eigentlich so gut wie jeden Abend, ja.
Haben Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nee, ich selber habe nie Drogen konsumiert, das konnte ich mir nie erlauben.
Seit wann rauchen Sie und seit wann trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also wann fängt man an mit Alkohol? Mit 18, 17, 18 trinkt man das erste Mal Bier und dann habe ich das natürlich erst mal nicht so regelmäßig gemacht, aber eigentlich seit dem Erwachsenenalter trinke ich regelmäßig Bier.
Schon lange Zeit.
Gibt es wichtige Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie? Krebs, Lungen?
Ja, wie gesagt, mein Bruder, das hat mich schon, ja das hat mich schon auch sehr geschockt muss ich sagen und das macht mir jetzt auch so ein bisschen Sorgen.
Und ja, meine Schwester, die hatte schon als Kind hier Zuckerkrankheit, also die hat richtig so eine kindliche Zuckerkrankheit gehabt.
Ihre Schwester?
Meine Schwester.
Aber sonst, ja auch mein Vater, der hatte, also in meinem Alter ungefähr, hatte der mein Herz infakt und inzwischen lebt der natürlich nicht mehr.
Ist er an Herzinfarkt gestorben oder?
Nein, also den hat er eigentlich überstanden, woran er dann letztendlich gestorben ist, weiß ich gar nicht genau. Also das kommen ja dann immer viele Sachen zusammen.
Und Ihre Mutter?
Ja, meine Mutter lebt inzwischen auch schon nicht mehr, aber die hatte jetzt auch keine irgendwie bekannten Erkrankungen oder sowas. Irgendwann ist halt gut.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand, Herr Kaiser?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Sie leben Ihre Frau oder?
Ja, die Kinder sind schon aus dem Haus, ja. Ich wohne hier mit meiner Frau zusammen, ja.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Zwei. Aber die sind natürlich, also keine Kinder mehr, sind erwachsen.
Ja, ja natürlich. Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, also da wüsste ich nicht, dass die irgendwelche grundlegenden Erkrankungen haben.
Sehr schön.
Und ich nehme an, Sie sind in Ruhe?
In Ruhe stand, ja zum Glück, ja. Das kann man nicht mehr so lange machen, ja.
Was haben Sie als?
Ich habe als Erzieher gearbeitet.
Ja, das war auch viel mit Schichtdienst und das war anstrengend und immer mit Jugendlichen und Kindern. Das war schon auch eine sehr anstrengende Arbeit, muss ich sagen.
Ja, ja, ich kann verstehen. Und ich möchte jetzt kurz zusammenfassen.
Sie haben ungefähr seit drei Wochen dauerhafte heftige Hüsten.
Sie haben keine Schmerzen und sie haben auch Fieber.
Diese Hüsten sind trocken. Sie haben keinen Auswurf.
Und sie fühlen sich schwach und müde und haben auch Übelkeit.
Gibt es noch etwas? Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, das trifft es schon so ziemlich genau, ja.
Ok, wir sind doch gleich fertig, Herr Kaiser.
Ich werde Sie körperlich untersuchen, dann Blut abnehmen. Dann sprechen wir über die nächsten Schritte.
Über die nächsten Schritte, ja. Ok, ja. Dann warte ich hier im Wartezimmer auf Sie, ja?
Ja, ich rufe Sie.
Ok, gut.
Herr Kaiser, da habe ich eine Frage gestellt.
Aber natürlich.
Ich bin die letzten sechs Monate im Ausland und ich habe...
Im Ausland war ich nicht, nein.
Ich bin nicht sicher. Gibt es einen Gewichtverlust?
Nein, hat er aber auch gefragt. Hat er gefragt, aber kann ich nicht bestätigen.
Und Impfung? Sind Sie gegen Inflanz oder Covid geimpft?
Ja, ich bin geimpft gegen Covid.
Und früher halt so, die Grippeimpfung und sowas habe ich alles gemacht, was man so als Rentner so empfohlen bekommt, ja.
Dr. Schopach, hatten Sie noch eine andere Frage außer der Reise an am Leben?
Ja, ja, ich habe auch. Wenn Sie tief einatmen, kriegen Sie eine Schmerzenunterrippe?
Sieben?
Tief einatmen?
Ich glaube nicht.
Sie genau. Danke.
Darf ich fragen?
Gerne, ja.
Seifann, haben Sie Beta-Belöcke eingenommen?
Oh, eigentlich seit das mit dem Blutdruck bekannt ist. Das ist auch schon über 20 Jahre her.
Ja.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Natürlich.
Haben Sie eine Klimaanlage zu Hause oder?
Eine Klimaanlage? Nein, sowas gibt es bei uns fast nirgendwo.
Und haben Sie Kontakt mit den exotischen Tieren?
Exotischen Tieren? Nee, damit habe ich wirklich nichts zu tun.
Vogel oder Igerfas?
Vogel.
Also ich habe keinen Papageien und auch nicht mal einen Wellensittich oder Kanarienvogel. Nein, Vogel habe ich nicht.
Ah, ja. Das ist tatsächlich auch noch eine interessante Frage, ob jemand in der Familie Ähnliches bestätigt hat. Kann er nicht bestätigen.
Sie sagen Bescheid, wenn Sie Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch starten wollen, oder?
Wir können starten.
Ja. Okay. Ich kann schon mal sagen, zeitlich waren Sie gut im Limit. Wir hatten ja jetzt noch ein paar Fragen und wir haben nicht voll angefangen. Also das war super.
Ja, gut. Dann schießen Sie los.
Es gibt eine Frage.
Blaue Lippen, ja. Ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Guten Abend, Frau Oberstin. Ich habe einen neuen Patienten. Haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich. Wen haben Sie gesehen?
Es handelt sich um Herrn Peter Kaiser. Er ist 72 Jahre alt, 1,78 Meter groß und 80 Kilo schwer.
Er kam zu uns wegen seit ungefähr drei Wochen bestehender Reishusten, zunehmender Reishusten. Er hat keinen Ausflug.
Er hat keinen Ausflug. Er ist sputum.
Diese Reishusten wurden mit der Zeit schlimmer. Es gibt keinen Auslöser dafür. Er berichtete über Arzttraining und Vertrieb.
Er war deswegen vor zwei Wochen beim Hausarzt und der Hausarzt hat einen Rüstenlöser ACC verschrieben.
Verschrieben?
Verschrieben, ja. Und die Frage nach Schlückung...
Hat Ihnen das denn geholfen?
Ein bisschen, aber eigentlich nichts.
Er leidet unter Fieber und berichtete über Inapetens insomni wegen Post-Aterbedingter Nykoterie.
Und die Frage nach Schlückbeschwerden, Brustengengefühl, Herzfasen, Schwellungen wurden verneint.
Er leidet an Benign Prostat Hypertrazie, Arteriella Hypertermina seit Jahren und Diabetes mellitus seit 50 Jahren.
50?
15 Jahre, Entschuldigung.
Also Typ 2 Diabetes, ne?
Ja, Typ 2. An Medikamenten nimmt er Metformin 850, einmal morgens, Prostat gut und Betabellocker einmal.
Aber er weiß nicht die Dosis und den Namen des Medikamenten.
Und mit 50 wurde Kolesi-Stechtome vorgenommen. Er hat keine Allergie.
Er braucht eine Packung Zigaretten täglich.
Auch jetzt?
Ja, auch. Und seit dem 18. Lebensjahr trinkt er auch 1-2 Flaschen Bier jeden Abend.
Und seine Eltern sind gestorben.
Na gut, bei dem Alter kein Wunder.
Ja, ja.
Und beim Vater ist Meokart infarktisch bekannt.
Sein Bruder leidet an Lungenkrebs, Lungenkarzinom und seine Schwester leidet an Diabetes mellitus. Er ist verheiratet.
Was für ein Diabetes mellitus?
Typ 2.
Okay.
Oder? Er ist verheiratet, lebt mit seiner Frau. Er hat zwei Kinder, sie sind gesund und er ist Rentner und als TH hat er gearbeitet.
Okay, ja. Was vermuten Sie denn jetzt?
Ich habe einen Verdacht auf atypische Pneumone.
Auf was?
Atypische Pneumone.
Ja, okay.
Und Akutbrunschitis vielleicht oder Influenza.
Ja, was könnte es noch sein?
Und Asthma kann ich sagen. Asthma, Brunschale oder CoPäde auch, aber er hat keinen Auswurf, keine Absputung.
Oder vielleicht er nimmt Betroblöcke ein und vielleicht deswegen hat er Zuckenerhusten.
Ja, okay.
Ja, das war alles.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch mit dem Patienten?
Zuerst würde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie dabei?
Natürlich Vita-Parameter sind wichtig. Er hat Fieber und ich kontrolliere Herz- und Atemverkaufswerte und Sauerstoffsättigung.
Ja, sehr gut. Sauerstoffsättigung, ja, genau.
Und bei der Inspektion achte ich darauf, ob zionische Dämenschwellung vorliegen.
Und was machen Sie noch bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Bei der Inspektion können wir Geräusche feststellen.
Und ich achte darauf, ob Erziehung in der Kostalraum.
Nochmal? Worauf achten Sie?
Erziehung.
Erziehung?
Ja.
Meinen Sie nicht, ne?
Einziehung, ja.
Ja, sehr gut. Eine Einziehung, ja.
Ja, aber, ja, genau.
Und Nasenflüge.
Ja.
Dann werde ich Blut abnehmen.
Jawohl, und das lassen Sie alles bestimmen?
Ja, ich werde Blutbild, CRP, also Akutfaseraktion, Nierenwerte, Elektrolyte und was noch?
Ja, vielleicht die Dämmer bestimmen.
Ja, ja. Und was machen Sie noch fürs Labor?
Labor?
Ja, und?
Und experimentieren.
Ja, das ist ja nicht fürs Labor. Aber ja, was wir tatsächlich auch nicht als Thema hier drin haben, als Differentialdiagnose, es könnte ja tatsächlich auch eine Covid-Infektion sein.
Ja, ja.
Das ist nicht richtig.
Deswegen Nasenrachen abstrichen, ne?
Ja.
Genau, ja. Und das fällt mir jetzt gerade ein, dass das tatsächlich als Differentialdiagnose nicht mit aufgeführt ist, weil das ein Fall ist, der von vor Covid kommt.
Achso.
Ja, deswegen, aber das wäre sicherlich eigentlich ein klassisches Ding da Covid-Tests zu machen, ne?
Gut, ja, was machen Sie noch mit den Patienten?
Torax entgehen werde ich.
Ja, auf alle Fälle.
Und gegebenenfalls CT-Torax und Spirometzig.
Ja, okay, gut. Und was machen Sie noch?
Ich denke, es gibt eine infektiöse Ursache.
Und möglicherweise, hochwahrscheinlich, gibt es eine Weichdose, die wir nicht in der Situation haben.
Und möglicherweise, hochwahrscheinlich gibt es eine Virusinfektion.
Ja, weiß ich jetzt gar nicht, ist das Virus oder Bakterie?
Ja.
Ja, würde man aber rausfinden tatsächlich über die Analysen.
Ja, ich kann das Geheimnis lüften für Sie.
Tatsächlich ist es ein Pertussis-Patient.
Ja, gibt es auch im hohen Alter erstaunlicherweise, Chorchusen, eigentlich eine Kinderkrankheit,
kann aber tatsächlich auch im hohen Alter dann nochmal oder auch im Anal-Lebensalter nochmal auftauchen.
Und dieser Patient hat also tatsächlich eine Pertussis.
Und ich finde das eigentlich insofern spannend, weil man eigentlich in die Richtung bei so einem Menschen nicht unbedingt denkt.
Und weil man auch denkt, das gibt es gar nicht mehr.
Das ist ja auch, wir werden als Babys ja heute geimpft.
Gegen Masern, Mums, Röteln und Chorchusen werden wir auch geimpft, meine ich.
Aber trotzdem kann es eben passieren. Und dieser Patient hat tatsächlich eine Pertussis gehabt.
Ja, das ist natürlich relativ exotisch.
Und sie waren ja sehr nah dran mit der Pneumonie, mit der Bronchitis, mit dem Asthma.
Und ich denke mal da sind sie schon sehr klar auf dem richtigen Pfad gewesen.
Und über das Fieber gibt es halt eigentlich nur diese Abklärung.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob man das nachweisen kann über Sputumkultur.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher.
Könnte aber sein. Ja, und ja, also ich würde sagen, sie haben eine sehr schöne Anamnese gemacht.
Sie haben auch einen guten Arzt-Arztbericht gemacht.
Das Einzige, sie hatten im Gespräch, haben sie vergessen, direkt im Gespräch nach dem Impfstatus und nach der Reiseanamnese zu fragen.
Das ist natürlich in so einem Fall, wo jemand so einen unklaren Husten hat, durchaus eine Frage, die interessant ist.
Irgendeiner ihrer Kollegen hat auch ja tatsächlich reingeschrieben, Tuberkulose als Differentialdiagnose.
Das sollte man auch nicht außer Acht lassen. Gibt es ja auch wieder.
Es war eigentlich ziemlich ausgerottet in Deutschland, aber es gibt immer wieder, nochmal wieder so aufflackernde Aufkommen.
Sollte man nicht so ganz außer Acht lassen, würde man aber ja ganz klar im Lungen-Röntgen-Bild sehen.
Gut, jetzt muss ich gerade überlegen mit der Kolisexaktomi.
Haben sie alles richtig gemacht?
Ja, er hat gesagt, er raucht jetzt im Augenblick nicht das ganze Päckchen am Tag, weil er so doll husten muss.
Ich denke mal, was ein richtiger Raucher ist, der wird schon natürlich weiter rauchen, aber nicht in dem vollen Umfang.
Die diagnostischen Maßnahmen sind auch alle klar.
Haben Sie eine Idee, was man mit den Patienten machen würde?
Wenn es sich um Pertussis handelt, empfehle ich Antibiotikum.
Was empfehlen Sie?
Antibiotikum.
Ja, auf alle Fälle. Und was noch?
Bei Bedarf Sauerstoffgabe und Schmessmittel.
Ja, sehr gut. Und was noch?
Was noch? Vielleicht hustenlose...
Ja, stattdessen, wenn Ihre Aufnahme kommt und Flüssigkeit zuvornimmt.
Ja, Flüssigkeit.
Das ist natürlich auch ein kritischer Punkt, gerade auch bei älteren Leuten.
Ich erinnere mich gerade daran, dass meine Kinder mich immer erinnern.
Ja, meine Mutter, trinkst du genug?
Also ältere Leute trinken oftmals nicht genug.
Das ist dann im Zusammenhang mit so einer husten Geschichte besonders zu beachten.
Und dann gibt es eben Antibiose.
Genau. Und Sauerstoff im Zweifelsfall.
Ja, ich würde mal sagen, das war doch wieder mal eine sehr schöne Anamnese von Ihnen.
Und sprachlich sind Sie sehr sicher unterwegs.
Sie machen diese Kleinigkeiten dann.
Ich werde das... Ich habe jetzt gleich gemowelt.
Aber Sie wissen das eigentlich. Sie wissen das eigentlich.
Sie wissen das eigentlich.
Und ja, ich denke, das ist nichts, worüber sich irgendjemand aufregen sollte.
Und die Münchner selber können auch nicht besser Deutsch.
Die mit ihrem Dialekt, die reden wirklich völlig unverständlich.
Leider.
Ich wünsche Ihnen natürlich, dass Sie einen Patienten haben, der anehrend Hochdeutsch spricht.
Also mit so einem Ur-Bayern haben Sie es natürlich schwer.
Mal gucken, was auf Sie zukommt.
Bayern ist sehr schwer.
Ich bin gespannt, was Sie dann am Ende erzählen. Wir halten Ihnen natürlich mit vereinten Kräften die Daumen.
Wie viel Uhr sind Sie dran? Das ist dann der Mittwoch erst, oder?
Ja, Mittwoch.
Wie viel Uhr sind Sie dran?
Wie bitte?
Um wie viel Uhr?
Ist Ihre Kuhfung?
Um 12 Uhr glaube ich.
Hi nun.
Also wie gesagt, wir werden mit vereinten Kräften an Sie denken.
Jetzt habe ich noch eine wichtige Information.
Jetzt sind aber die entscheidenden Leute auch nicht da.
Ich bin wieder bei meinen Enkelkindern.
Werde sicherlich am Dienstag keine Anamnese machen können.
Das weiß ich sicher, weil mein Sohn da nämlich außer Haus ist und ich die Kinder ins Bett bringen muss.
Ich habe zwei von drei.
Da werde ich sicherlich unsicher sein, ob ich rechtzeitig fertig bin.
Ich versuche es am Donnerstag.
Da würde ich aber zur Sicherheit sagen 21 Uhr.
Ich nehme mir ein paar Fälle mit.
Und mein iPad sowieso.
Und dann können wir...
Ach guck mal, nett. Ihr Kollege wünscht Ihnen viel Glück bei der Prüfung.
Das ist doch mal gut.
Und wir sehen uns dann also potenziell am Donnerstag.
Und ich würde mich freuen, wenn wir dann von Ihnen hören, wie es Ihnen ergangen ist.
Und am besten natürlich, dass alles perfekt gelaufen ist.
So würden wir das gerne hören.
Gut. Ich werde mich noch bei Dr. Gündis und bei...